MALE SPEAKER: This is
David Gelles, joining us
from "The New York Times,"
where he's a business reporter.
He's also an author
of "Mindful Work."
And he's written
about his experiences
with meditation, both
personally and in the workplace
and many businesses
around the world.
So without further
ado, here's David.
DAVID GELLES: Thank you.
Thanks, all, so much for
being here, really happy--
you're all my guinea
pigs because I've never
given this talk before.
So bear with me, please.
So before I rattle on about
mindless and meditation,
I thought it would
be appropriate
if we just stopped for
just a second here.
So if you would, you're
all being so diligent.
You don't have your
smart phones out.
You don't have
your laptops open.
But if they are, if
you're hiding them,
just put them away
for just a sec.
And when I ring this bell, just
close your eyes if you would
and focus on the sensation
of your breath, just
the actual feeling of air moving
in and out of your nostril,
wherever you feel it.
Maybe it's your lungs
moving up and down,
your chest inflating,
your diaphragm rising.
And then here's the whole game.
When you notice
your mind wander,
just try to bring
your attention back
to that physical
sensation of the breath.
We'll just do it for
very short minute here.
[BELL RINGING]
If you find yourself wondering
when this is going to be over,
just gently bring your
attention back to the breath.
[BELL RINGING]
OK, not so painful, I
hope, and like it or not,
you're all now meditators.
But before we get
started, I just
want a quick show
of hands-- 0 to 10.
Zero means you think
this is all hokum
and you don't even
know why I'm up here.
And meditation and business have
absolutely no place together.
10 is you're already leading
the search inside yourself.
I expect to see a 10 from
Don in the back, there.
So 0 to 10, just give me your
initial impressions-- 0s, 10s.
OK, let me see what we have.
We have sixes, sevens.
I know I'm at Google.
We have a five.
OK, any twos or threes?
No, you guys are so
welcome and receptive.
OK, that's good.
Those that are on the lower
end of the scale, I hear you.
I was a skeptic at once, too.
In fact, I'm a "New
York Times" journalist,
so I'm paid to be cynical.
But I hope what we'll find is
that that simple practice we
just did is catching on in the
business world for good reason.
At Goldman Sachs, a company
I cover pretty closely
for "The New York Times," a
board member, Bill George,
is actually espousing the
virtues of meditation.
And traders and
investment bankers
are practicing mindfulness,
trying to get an edge.
At Facebook-- a cross-town
rival of your guys'-- they have
actually retooled some of
their algorithms to try to make
the social network
more compassionate.
They have compassion
research days.
You guys might want
to catch up there.
At General Mills,
there's a meditation room
in every building on
the corporate campus
in the middle of the Midwest,
in Minneapolis, Minnesota.
And it's not just business.
In health care, doctors,
nurses, and patients
are all finding value in
mindfulness and meditation
for one reason or another.
Doctors and nurses
find it makes them
more resilient for these
long 12 hour shifts.
And patients are discovering
that mindfulness and meditation
might not make the
pain go away, but it
can help them manage
their suffering.
Students as well,
teachers also-- teachers
find that mindfulness
can help them
deal with rambunctious
little children.
And students, younger and
even college students,
are actually-- there are
studies that show this-- finding
that mindfulness and meditation
can actually improve their test
scores, help them be
more focused at work.
The US military, both Marines
and soldiers in the army,
are using mindfulness
and meditation,
not to become better snipers,
but to become more resilient
when they're back home and
also on the battlefield.
And even the Seattle Seahawks--
this is Russell Wilson.
He's playing in the
Super Bowl on Sunday.
They've made mindfulness
a core part of training
at the Seattle
Seahawks training camp.
And some would say
that that's helped
them appear in two
consecutive Super Bowls.
At the World Economic Forum,
I was just in Davos last week,
every day started with an hour
of mindfulness meditation led
by Jon Kabat-Zinn, who's
one of the guys that really
got this movement
going many years ago
and has sustained it for
the last several decades.
And I wrote a story
about it for the times--
"Amid the Chattering of
the Global Elite, a Silent
Interlude."
There was a panel about
mindful leadership,
and there was another one
later in the week about mindful
neuroscience.
Of all the things we wrote
about, from central bankers
to oil prices, this
was the one that
was the most read of
all our Davos coverage.
And there's even a
magazine. "Mindful Magazine"
is on the newsstands,
documenting
this whole range of
professionals that
are embracing mindfulness
for one reason
or another-- doctors,
lawyers, policeman, and more.
So what is mindfulness?
For those who
haven't taken gPause,
who haven't taken
Search Inside Yourself,
it's paying attention
in the present moment,
on purpose, in a particular
way, and nonjudgmentally.
And I know that's a mouthful.
But if you boil it
down, it's really
about being right
here, right now.
It's doing what we did for
just a minute earlier on.
It's not letting
ourselves get caught up
on the hamster
wheel of our minds,
not letting ourselves
be always preoccupied
about the future,
dwelling on the past.
It's being right here
right now and noticing
what's going on in our
thoughts, emotions, and bodies.
Who coined this term?
Jon Kabat-Zinn-- he's
a molecular biologist
from the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology.
So he's not just
hippie vagabond who
came back and tried to
repurpose some ancient wisdom.
He's a very serious guy, and
he's done more than anyone
over the last several decades.
He developed this thing called
mindfulness-based stress
reduction.
It's an eight week course.
It's taught here in London.
I highly recommend it.
I've done it, and it really has
helped secularize mindfulness.
It's made it so
accessible to people
in all those professions.
And I think I wouldn't
be on the stage
if it wasn't for
the work he'd do.
So how does Jon Kabat-Zinn
suggest we actually
cultivate mindfulness?
Well, meditation--
it's not the only way,
but it's unfortunately the
main way-- and more meditation.
And let's just think
back to what we did.
It's sitting upright,
comfortably--
it's what we just did-- finding
the sensation of your breath.
And the whole game, this
is the whole thing, when
your mind wanders, just
bring your attention
back to the breath.
Let's just do it one more time,
this time for only 30 seconds.
Find a position that's upright,
dignified, comfortable.
And when I ring the bell,
just focus on your breath.
I won't interrupt this time.
When the mind wanders,
back to the breath.
[BELL RINGING]
OK, not so painful, I hope--
that was just 30 seconds.
I don't know.
How long do you guys
sit for at gPause, Don?
20 minutes, OK,
that's 40 of those.
I think we could do it.
We're not going to
do it today, though.
But sitting meditation can
be a lot for some people,
so it's not the only way.
There's sitting meditation,
but there's also
walking meditation.
There's the body scan.
And I'll talk about a
few other techniques
over the course of this talk
that are ways just to pause
and be mindful in the midst
of our busy work days.
And what happens
when we actually
start embodying
this mindfulness?
Well, a common
way it's described
is a move from
reaction to response.
So something happens, and
typically we just automatically
respond.
We react.
And oftentimes, we
don't even think
about what it is we're going to
do, how we're going to respond,
where we're going to come
from, the quality of presence
we're going to bring
to that interaction.
Mindfulness--
cultivating the ability
to just pause for
these brief seconds--
allows us to inject
mindfulness after that stimulus
and respond.
And often the result is more
equanimity, more harmonious
interactions.
It can be good, especially in
a busy, big place like Google.
Mindfulness is an
innate human quality.
This is nothing specific.
This is nothing that
Jon Kabat-Zinn invented.
You all just found mindfulness
right here, in Google,
in London, for just a
minute, for just 30 seconds.
It's something that we all
possess, and yet it is true,
it is most closely associated
with the Buddhist tradition.
The term mindfulness is
sprinkled across the Buddhist
text like stars
across the night.
And Buddhist meditation
is often aimed
at actually cultivating
the quality of mindfulness.
But today, thanks
largely to Jon Kabat-Zinn
and some of his
colleagues, mindfulness
is really a secular pursuit.
It's been divorced
from that tradition.
They've taken it out of
that religious context
and really made it
accessible to everyone.
And I think that's why
we're seeing Google, Goldman
Sachs, General Mills,
and more embrace this.
And also, a company
called Aetna.
This is Mark Bertolini.
He's the CEO of Aetna.
It's a $40 billion, Fortune
100 company, big health care
provider in the United States.
And I'm just going to tell
you his story for a minute.
Several years ago,
Mark almost died.
He was in a skiing accident
with his family on vacation.
He broke his collar bone.
His shoulder was dislocated,
and he tore a ton of the nerves
in his arm.
And when he got back,
he could barely work.
The pain was so severe
that he almost quit.
He almost absolutely
didn't even return to work.
He tried drugs.
The drugs didn't work.
He tried all of them.
He tried physical therapy.
Physical therapy didn't work,
and he was really suffering.
He was considering ending his
career, and he was a real up
and comer.
Then finally someone
suggested, you try yoga.
And he said, no way, no how.
Yoga is for sissies, not for me.
He was a very serious,
type A kind of guy.
And they said,
just try it, Mark.
So he went to his
first yoga class,
and he did his Sun Salutations.
And he got through it.
And the next day, he
was so sore he almost
wanted those drugs again.
And he realized that not only
was yoga not for sissies,
it was a very serious practice
that he ought to investigate.
He became a devoted
yogi, and that
led to an experience
of mindfulness.
He started practicing
mindfulness meditation.
Fast forward several months.
He's off the drugs.
He still feels pain, absolutely.
But like the patients
I mentioned earlier,
he's not suffering as much.
He's able to manage his
pain more effectively.
And he goes.
He wasn't CEO at that point.
He becomes CEO, and Aetna is
frankly doing better than ever.
So then he says, well,
if it works for me,
why don't we bring
it to our employees?
So he goes to his chief
medical officer at Aetna
and he says, I want to teach
mindfulness to Aetna employees.
And Lonnie, this guy,
he says, you're crazy.
Just because everyone
else is meditating,
it doesn't mean your
employees have to as well.
And he said, we're an
evidence-based company.
Let's just try it.
And Lonnie says, fine,
small pilot-- couple hundred
employees on both coasts.
Mark says, I'll
do you one better.
Let's get Duke University
in to measure the results.
So they start it-- small
pilot program, run it
for a few months.
What do they find?
Those few hundred
employees-- a., they love it,
say the quality of life,
their experience of work,
has gone up.
But not only that, they
seem to be healthier.
They seem to be less stressed.
They were reporting their
self-reported stress symptoms
way down.
Their engagement
with work, way up.
So Lonnie, the chief medical
officer, he says, OK,
let's expand it.
They roll it out
then to thousands
of Aetna employees
around the country.
And, again, it's a hit.
After a year of this,
they look at all the data.
They look at all the results,
and it's made a difference.
Not only are all the
self-reported scores
off the charts-- people love
it, they're feeling better--
but in fact, health
care costs at Aetna
for that first full year
came down dramatically.
They came down 9%, which
for Aetna was $7 million.
And I asked Mark.
I said, is that all
directly-- are you telling me
meditation saved you $7 million?
He said, I can't make
that direct corollary.
I'm not going to overstep here.
But he has to believe it made
a difference on the margins.
If his employees
are less stressed,
feeling better, going
to the infirmary less,
taking fewer sick
days, maybe that's
going to help the bottom line.
So what did they do?
They did mindfulness.
They did yoga, but
they also rolled out
other forms of
mindfulness training.
And there's one I want to
mention as another tip.
And it involves the sandwich--
actually just eating, eating
anything.
Aetna rolled out a program
called Metabolic Bytes.
And he actually
got his employees
to focus on what
they were eating,
how much they were eating.
And what did they do when
they started to do that?
They started to eat less.
And through this whole
program, they actually
engaged a bunch of the
overweight and obese Aetna
employees.
And they were actually able
to help them lose weight,
just through
mindfulness of eating.
And it's bringing that
same quality of attention
that we practiced
earlier to our attention.
And what do we notice?
So often we're just shovelling
food and maybe surfing
our smartphone, looking at
the web at the same time,
eating at our desk.
When we stop doing
that, we can actually
eat just what we need
instead of automatically
finishing everything
on the table.
And that was an
amazing, amazing thing
that I've tried to take with me.
I try to eat at my desk
less than I need to.
But at "The New York Times"
it's not always an option.
But when I actually
find the time,
a good mindful meal can help.
So Aetna brought it to
thousands of people.
He saved millions in
health care costs,
then he started offering it to
other companies as a service.
So Aetna now offers yoga
and meditation classes
to many of its employees.
So if that all weren't enough,
I was totally impressed
with Aetna.
And then Mark, just
this month, did
something really incredible.
He came back from
Christmas vacation,
and he had read this book--
"Capital in the Twenty-First
Century" by Thomas Piketty.
And he was so moved by
the stories of inequality
and the data that showed that
big corporations, like the one
he runs, and big CEOs, like
him-- he's paid millions
of dollars a year--
were exacerbating this
that he felt compelled
to do something.
So he went to his board.
He gave everyone in the
board a copy of this book.
And then he made a
public announcement.
Out of the blue he
said, all of our lowest
paid workers are
getting a 33% raise
because I have an
obligation to do something
about this problem.
And I saw Mark in Davos.
And I said, Mark, did
your meditation practice,
did your mindfulness, have
anything to do with this?
And he said, I'm not
going to tell you
just because I meditated
I made this decision.
But meditation and
mindfulness have
made me more attuned to
other people's emotions.
I'm more compassionate.
I'm more in touch with
the needs of others.
And I recognize
the interdependence
and the interconnectedness
of the work we do
and the broader
function of society.
And, ultimately, he made
this very radical decision.
So why am I the guy up
here telling you this,
you might wonder?
I grew up here in
the San Francisco
Bay, beautiful
Northern California.
And I was a confused kid.
I was a confused teenager.
I was a confused
college student.
I asked lots of questions
about the big things in life.
And I found no answers
in psychedelics.
I found no answers in books.
I tried everywhere, but
I couldn't find them.
Then finally one night, it's
my first year of college.
I'm home visiting my mom.
I open a book on the
bookshelf, and it's
an introduction to basic
Buddhist meditation.
And for the first time, I read
something that makes sense.
It says getting off the hamster
wheel of our mind is possible.
Stopping obsessing about
the future and the past
is actually attainable.
And there's an
easy way to do it,
and it's called
mindfulness and meditation.
So I did what anyone would do.
I got on a plane and went
as far away from my parents
as I could to India.
And I moved to Bodh Gaya, which
is a small, impoverished town
in Northern India.
And it's where the Buddha, they
say, was actually enlightened.
I moved into a
Burmese monastery,
where saffron-robed monks
woke me up every morning.
There were peacocks
roaming the courtyard,
and I studied with
different meditation masters
for several months.
I studied with Zen masters.
I studied with supposedly
reincarnated Tibetan rinpoches,
and I studied with
this guy, Munindraji.
Anagarika Munindraji was
one of the most influential
mindfulness teachers
of the 20th century.
The students he taught
are still so responsible
for the proliferation
of mindfulness
that we're seeing today.
And I was really fortunate
to spend quite a lot of time
with him in the last
years of his life.
And he emphasized more than
anything else, more than all
the different
meditation techniques,
he said something that
just resonated with me.
He said, moment to moment,
everything you do, be mindful.
If you're walking, be mindful.
If you're eating be mindful.
If you're just sitting
there, be mindful.
Don't let your
mind just race off.
Just actually practice
being here now.
So there I am, sitting with
Munindraji under the Bodhi
tree.
I was younger then.
There I am with another Tibetan
teacher, under the Bodhi tree
again.
And if I had stayed in India,
as I was tempted to do--
I called my mom and I threatened
I was going to stay there,
and she freaked out.
If I had stayed
in India, I think
I would look like this guy.
That's Yogi Mike, and he's been
in India for a very long time.
I didn't stay in India, though.
I came back.
I became a business journalist.
I'm currently with
"The New York Times."
Before that, I was with "The
Financial Times" for five years
here in London, covering
media, marketing acquisitions.
And I continue to meditate.
I go to places like this,
Spirit Rock, north of Northern
California, just
above San Francisco.
But for the most
part, this has been
my temple-- the
newsroom of newspapers,
full of screaming
editors, fast deadlines.
And I can assure you
after much experience,
it's about the least
mindful place I can imagine.
But it's where I earn my keep.
It was while I was at the
FT that I wrote a magazine
article that actually led
me to this stage right here.
It was called "The
Mind Business."
It was published in 2012.
And I wrote it when I was
kind of at an impasse.
I had done a bunch
of big stories.
I had interviewed
Bernie Madoff in prison.
I had profiled
Zuckerberg in 2011,
right as the company was
gearing up for that big push
to go public.
But I was at an impasse.
I didn't have a big
story I was working on,
which for a journalist is about
the most frustrating thing.
And then I heard about this
company, General Mills.
I heard General
Mills in Minneapolis,
Minnesota was actually teaching
their employees to meditate.
And a light bulb went off.
I said, I have to figure this.
This is finally the
moment where I can join up
these two disparate
parts of my life.
So I got on a plane,
flew out there,
eager to see what the
makers of Haagen-Dazs ice
cream and Cheerios had to
tell me about meditation.
And when I got there,
this is what I found.
It looked so similar to
actually the very things
we had been doing in India.
I walked into this
conference room.
It was 3 o'clock on
a Tuesday, and people
were meditating
in total silence.
And not only that, but the
phrases they were using,
the very words, were echoes
of what I had heard in India.
And the woman who was leading
all this was Janice Marturano.
Janice had a story
not unlike Mark's.
She had hit rock bottom.
She was the deputy general
counsel at General Mills.
And for a year, she worked to
push through the $10 billion
merger of Pillsbury
and General Mills.
It was absolutely draining.
She had to fight the
SEC, fight the FTC.
It was grueling.
And in the midst of
this professional toil,
both of her parents
died, a personal blow
that absolutely levelled her.
She finally got the
deal passed, but when
she got back to
work she was spent.
She had nothing
left in the tank.
She was emotionally,
intellectually
just depleted-- felt like
she almost couldn't go on.
A friend suggested
she try meditation.
She said, no way, no
how, not new age for me.
I'm a solid Midwestern
girl, not going to happen.
Finally, she circled
back a few weeks later,
said, tell me a bit
more about that.
Soon she was on a
plane to Arizona,
where she studied
with Jon Kabat-Zinn,
the molecular
biologist from MIT.
After a day with
Jon Kabat-Zinn, she
was ready to get back on
the plane to Minneapolis.
After five days, she
didn't want to leave.
It took a while, but
meditation started
to change the way
she saw herself
and the way she
was able to work.
She got back to Minneapolis, and
people noticed she had changed.
There was a bounce
back in her step.
In very stressful meetings,
she was able to keep her cool,
even as people around
her were blowing up.
And finally people started
asking her, what's changed?
Are you OK?
What's different?
And she started telling
them, well, I've
been practicing meditation.
I've been practicing
mindfulness.
If you're interested,
let me know.
Before long she had a quorum.
She had a dozen
people, and so she
started sitting-- much as
sitting groups have started
in companies all around
the globe right now.
And soon, that 12
turned into 20.
20 turned into 100.
General Mills heard about this.
The higher ups, they said,
OK, let's sanction it.
Let's build a program around it.
They gave her the
autonomy and the budget
to start a mindful
leadership program.
They started doing the research.
And now, there's
a meditation room
in every building on General
Mills' corporate campus.
It's just an extraordinary
testament to their commitment
to this.
And Janice, she teaches
sitting meditation.
She teaches walking meditation,
which we unfortunately
don't have time for today.
But she also talks about
the purposeful pause.
And that's that interjection
of mindfulness between stimulus
and our response
or our reaction.
Previously, she would just
grab the phone when it rang.
It's certainly what
I am trained to do.
As a mergers and
acquisitions reporter,
it could always be a
source giving me a tip.
And I have to stop myself.
So what I try to do is
when the phone rings,
I just let it ring
once, maybe even twice.
And guess what?
The people are still
on the other line
waiting to talk to me.
But just interjecting that brief
pause to check in with myself,
to check in with how
my body is feeling,
it allows me to come from
a place of equanimity
when I pick up that phone.
And it's amazing how
much can be accomplished
with even a few seconds.
Here, more General
Mills employees
trying a different kind
of purposeful pause.
Now, the mind business
went viral, in as much
as an article for the
Financial Times can.
People wanted to know
who else was doing this,
where could they find
it, what was the data.
And I didn't have
any of those answers.
It was more than two
years ago at this point.
I wanted to know more, and
so I set out on this journey
into the contemplative
heart of the business world.
I found all these companies and
more are practicing mindfulness
and meditation in
one way or another.
And it's really picking up
steam-- small businesses,
large businesses, and
companies like Green Mountain.
Green Mountain
Coffee-- I think you're
spared their K-Cups here, but
many businesses across the US
are subjected to them.
They make prepackaged coffee.
And the CEO, Bob
Stiller, that's him
as pictured in "Fortune
Magazine" some years ago.
He, unlike maybe Mark
Bertolini and Janice Marturano,
he was kind of a hippy.
He traveled through Asia.
Before he took
over Green Mountain
and made it a
multi-billion-dollar business,
he started EZ Wider
Rolling Paper Company.
So you get the sense of
the kind of guy he was.
But at a certain point, he
said, heck, I'm a billionaire.
I've made this big company.
I'm going to do want,
started teaching mindfulness
to his inner sanctum
of employees, his just
core executive team.
They loved it, same story.
They rolled it out
to more employees,
to middle management--
to graphic designers,
to supply chain managers in the
corporate office in Vermont.
Everyone loved it.
And then, finally, they did
something really wonderful,
I think.
They said, this is great,
but we have tens of thousands
of employees in factories
around the country.
These are the guys on the
floor, driving trucks,
who every day work
12 hour shifts
putting our coffee in boxes,
getting them on trucks,
and delivering it.
They're probably more
stressed than we are.
And they were right.
So they started working
with a yoga teacher,
and they developed mindful
yoga, mindful stretching,
that now Green Mountain
employees do before they start
every shift, just 10
minutes of mindful
stretching in the locker rooms
as they're getting ready.
And the locker room, the
environment in the locker room,
has actually changed.
It's quite extraordinary.
And this is another
tip I want to suggest.
Some people-- for Green
Mountain employees on the floor,
it's their locker room.
They just find a
mindfulness zone,
somewhere in the
building, in the office,
where it's your
cue to just pause,
to put away your smartphone, to
stop the incessant chattering
of the mind and
actually just check in.
And you can practice the
same kind of meditation
we did even if you're
just standing up.
For me, it sometimes
the elevator.
When I take the elevator up to
the cafeteria in "The New York
Times" building, I just
try to put my phone away.
And it's just 30 seconds or so.
But when I get off that
elevator, I'm somewhat renewed.
I'm refreshed.
It's a purposeful
pause that's allowed
me to just recenter
myself and carry on.
So what is all this doing?
Well, one thing is it's
making us less stressed.
Mindfulness, it's been proven
through study after study,
can actually reduce
our stress levels.
We've heard it from the
different companies,
but there's a lot of academic
and scientific research
that proves as much.
It's one of the reasons that
Jon Kabat-Zinn zeroed in
on mindfulness-based
stress reduction.
Mindfulness is a universal
sort of suffering.
It's something we
all can relate to.
We'd all love to be
less stressed, right?
And so he didn't say that
mindfulness is about making us,
you know, enlightened
or anything.
He said, just make us
a little less stressed.
That would be a
good thing, indeed.
And the World
Health Organization
estimates that stress costs
businesses $300 billion a year.
Now, that's, like, one of those
abstract numbers from studies.
I don't actually know what it
means, but I take the point.
If we're all a
little less stressed,
I got to believe that businesses
would be a bit more functional,
maybe even a bit
more profitable.
Mindfulness also seems
to improve our focus.
Just think about the exercise
we did, bringing our attention
back to the breath
over and over.
Just as going to the gym
builds the muscles in our arms,
so, too, mindfulness can build
up those attentional muscles,
our capacity to sustain our
focus, to stay concentrated.
And there's a great study that
shows that meditation actually
reduces task switching.
So that is they gave office
workers a series of tasks,
then they measured
how they did them.
And no surprise, they were
kind of balking back and forth.
They did email for 30 minutes.
They did a little PowerPoint.
They balked to their calendar.
They wrote a report.
They made an itinerary.
Then they trained them
all in mindfulness,
waited awhile, and
tried it again.
And what did they do?
The office workers, this
time, stayed on task
for almost double
the amount of time.
So they weren't super employees.
They didn't get everything
done twice as fast,
but they were actually
able to sustain their focus
on basic tasks in
the office and not
have this perpetual constant
ADD from which so many of us
suffer.
This focus, this kind
of being in the zone,
is, I think, why
a lot of athletes
are finding meditation to
be so effective as well.
This is Russell
Okung, also appearing
in the Super Bowl on Sunday.
You'd think I'm a Seahawks fan.
I'm actually a Patriots
fan, but the Seahwaks
have really embraced this.
And he talks about
meditation as being
just as important
as lifting weights.
It's about quieting your mind.
And from a 6 foot 6, 300
pound guy with a $48 million
contract, I'm not going
to argue with him.
Also this focus is one of
the reasons why meditation
seems to improve test scores.
They've done a series
of tests and studies
that show that compared to
control groups that haven't had
mindfulness training,
the students that
have had mindfulness training
seem to perform better
on standardized test
scores in the US.
This is a good time to mention
that this isn't all just coming
out of nowhere.
For the last several
decades, neuroscientists
have been studying the
minds of meditators,
trying to understand what's
going on in their heads.
And this study of
meditation has coincided
with a shift in the
world of neuroscience
where they actually
have re-thought
about the way we
understand our brains.
For a long time, much
of the 20th century,
it was assumed that the
brain kind of matured,
it degraded, and that was it.
Now we know that
there's actually
something called
neuroplasticity.
Our brains respond to whatever
stimulus we put in them.
That's why in the
brains of violinists
the part of the brain
responsible for acute motor
function is much more highly
developed than in my brain,
for example.
And in the minds of meditators,
certain areas of the brain
also appear to
become more robust.
The prefrontal cortex,
which is evolutionarily
the newest part of our brain, it
actually shows more gray matter
in the brains of
mindfulness meditators.
This is the part of the brain
responsible for higher order
processing, our reason,
our executive functioning.
And then the amygdala, which is
a little seahorse shaped region
in the center of our brain that
releases stress hormones when
we get anxious, when we
have that fight or flight
reaction-- in the minds of
meditators, it's less reactive.
It releases fewer hormones
when we do have a stimulus.
And again, there's that pause
between stimulus and response.
Mindfulness seems to give us
a bit more room right there.
So here's scans of the minds
of a non-meditator on the left.
This is your brain.
This is your brain
on meditation.
That's more gray matter
in the prefrontal cortex.
I also had my brain scanned at
Yale by a great neuroscientist
named Jud Brewer, and
this is what they found.
And mindfulness, of course,
doesn't just change our brains.
It changes our bodies, too.
We heard it from others earlier.
It can help the immune system.
There's an amazing study
that Jon Kabat-Zinn did.
It was one of the seminal ones
that really put him on the map.
He gave the flu vaccine
to a large group.
Then they gave them mindfulness
meditation to half the group.
And compared to
the control group,
those with the
mindfulness meditation,
their immune systems responded
so much more strongly.
And another amazing study
about patients with psoriasis,
the skin defect--
they gave mindfulness
meditation to
psoriasis patients who
were getting standard
light box treatment.
This is where they put them
in a kind of UV light box.
It helps with the
skin irritation.
And the patients that had
mindfulness meditation
at the same time as the UV
responded and healed much,
much faster than those who
were only getting the light box
therapy.
So less stressed, more
focused, maybe even
healthier-- what about
more compassionate,
maybe even kinder, too?
That's the message from
this guy, Tim Ryan.
He's a congressman
on Capitol Hill, part
of the House of
Representatives, which
is about the least
mindful place in America
after "The New York
Times" newsroom.
And he, for a long time,
was not a meditator.
He's a 6 foot 4
college quarterback
from Ohio, red-blooded
Catholic guy.
After his second
term, though, he
was preparing to get sworn
in for his third term,
and the bickering, the
partisan fighting in Congress,
was just too much for him.
He needed something.
He heard about Jon Kabat-Zinn.
He went on a short retreat
with Jon Kabat-Zinn,
and he came back renewed.
He said, this is it.
He wrote a book called
"A Mindful Nation."
He's become the most
unlikely meditation advocate
in the country.
He has quiet time caucus.
They meditate before
sessions on Capitol Hill.
There he is in his office.
And he is just doing
amazing things,
even if the rest of
Congress can't get onboard.
But I said, Tim, what has
actually been the difference?
I mean, how has it changed
the way you do your job?
And he said so often
before his calculations,
the bills he was
going to introduce,
the legislation he
was going to support,
was based on his own
impression of what
he was supposed to be doing.
What was going to advance
his political career?
What was the right
move for the party?
Instead, he says now, he's
really much more in touch
with his constituents.
He's gotten out of his own
head, and he has the time
to really listen to people
from Columbus and Cincinnati,
the cities he represents.
And he says, you
actually slow down enough
to pay attention to someone
other than yourself-- more
sympathetic, empathetic,
or compassionate.
And it's an
extraordinary testament,
and he's doing very good
work allocating resources
to veterans, to schools
in his home district,
trying to bring mindfulness
into schools and VA centers.
So maybe a bit more
compassionate on the margins,
socially responsible,
perhaps, as well-- this guy
would argue so.
This is Yvon Chouinard.
He's the founder of Patagonia,
the apparel company,
a long-time Zen Buddhist, even
before he founded Patagonia.
And he created a
very unusual company.
They don't necessarily teach
meditation at the Patagonia
campus, even though it's
a very idyllic place.
Instead, he's really
empowered his top executives
to bring the attitude
of mindfulness-- mindful
consumption, an awareness
of the company's impact
on the planet-- into all
their business decisions.
So once a year, they
run this ad that says
don't buy this jacket.
And it's a really
subversive thing.
They're saying, you
may want this jacket.
But guess what?
You probably don't need it.
So it's asking us just
to question ourselves.
And it plays into
this broader movement
called mindful
consumption, where
the principles of
mindfulness are trying
to be put in and adopted by
retailers, who are asking us
not to consume more and more
and more, as we're want to do,
but actually to
take what we need.
And Yvon, I asked him.
I said, this can't be
good for your business.
And he said, I think we
can reach more people
but sell less to
each one of them.
That's his goal.
He would like you to not buy
five Patagonia products a year.
He'd rather you buy one
Patagonia product every five
years but have a much broader
audience around the world.
And that's their mission.
Another example
is Eileen Fisher.
She, on the other hand, was
not a long-time meditator.
She developed a very successful
company-- her own brand,
Eileen Fisher women's clothing.
And it was great.
It was a success.
But she got well
into her career,
and she was feeling
somewhat empty.
So she started practicing yoga.
She started
practicing meditation,
and all of a sudden,
the world kind of
opened up to her as it
did with Mark Bertolini.
And she realized she
had a responsibility
not only to her
employees, but also
to her customers and
the environment as well.
And so she started by
changing just the way
things worked at the company.
She did away with square tables.
Everyone has meetings
in a circle now.
She offered meditation
and mindfulness,
did away with some of
the corporate hierarchy.
And guess what?
Her employees, no
surprise, loved it.
But then she made that step
that Green Mountain coffee did.
She said, well, what
about the workers
at the very end of
my supply chain?
A lot of her clothes were made
in China, and so she said,
I have a responsibility
to these people as well.
She started offering education,
better health care, and then
women's entrepreneurship
programs,
trying to get her factory
workers actually out
of her factories.
She wants them to start
their own businesses--
and just another extraordinary
example of something
Eileen says she has
done, motivated largely
by her mindfulness and
meditation practice.
So in some of these
examples, mindfulness
has come from the top down--
Mark Bertolini, Eileen Fisher.
Executives decided they
were into it, pushed it down
to their employees.
Other examples, like Janice
Marturano, bottom up.
So mindfulness is happening
in all sorts of ways,
and it's still
pretty early days.
And what are some ways we
can be mindful at work?
Well, we did our
sitting meditation.
And bringing that same
quality of attention
to eating a sandwich,
picking up the phone,
or just riding the elevator
can all be effective techniques
to just slow down in the middle
of our very, very busy work
days.
And now, if we
just have a minute,
I'd love to hear some ways
that you all are mindful.
And if we could, I'll
just turn to the audience.
And I think a mic's
going around, just
for a couple people.
And I'm going to
put Don on the spot
here because he's actually
my host, generous host,
but also has done Search
Inside Yourself and gPlus.
So what are some
ways that you've
found to be able to
be mindful at work?
DON: So I mean aside from
our daily sits, obviously,
just taking a little bit
of extra time to consider
replies that I'm
sending, especially
in emails since we're a
very email driven company.
As many people are
aware, email is actually
a really terrible
communications medium.
So taking a few extra
seconds after you've
written an email, if it's a
particularly sensitive topic
especially, maybe step
away from the computer.
Go make myself a tea, have a
few minutes or a few seconds
of really thinking, getting
focused, getting together,
and not taking that instinctive
reaction of, you know,
sort of irritation or
grumpiness that you often get
and using that opportunity
to tone things down,
that's actually made
people a lot more receptive
to what I'm asking them to do.
And I think it's made
people-- it's made it easier
for me to communicate
with teammates in London,
teammates in
California, teammates
in other parts of the world.
And that for me has been a
big improvement, definitely.
DAVID GELLES: That's great.
I mean, that sounds like
that purposeful pause,
just stopping, being a bit more
mindful before we automatically
react.
Is there anyone else?
Can we get one or two more
people maybe who have practiced
or who have found ways to
just be a little bit more
mindful at work?
I'm going pick on you.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying not
to eat my lunch at my desk.
And even if you're
really busy, just
trying to get up and step away.
And even if it's just sitting by
yourself and having your lunch,
you know, just away from all
the chatter with your teammates
and things like that.
DAVID GELLES: That's great.
Is there one more maybe?
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID GELLES: Say it one
more time to the mic.
AUDIENCE: When I am challenged
to [INAUDIBLE] my password
for OTP, I normally
just pause for a moment.
DAVID GELLES: That's great.
AUDIENCE: And my
specific variety of pause
is typically a prayer.
So it's a Christian
variant of this,
but I find this same value.
DAVID GELLES:
Absolutely, that's great.
OK, well, we just heard
a bunch of great ideas.
So I just need your
feedback one more time.
You are all a overly sympathetic
audience to begin with.
But let's just see again.
After hearing the
stories of executives
around the world
who are practicing
this and the studies that have
been done, quick show of hands.
Zero is it's hokum.
10 is you're all signing
up for sitting tomorrow.
Where are we?
Let's see.
All right, I see more
fingers than I did before.
That's good news.
Unfortunately,
mindfulness is no panacea.
It's not going to make
your boss behave better.
the workday any shorter.
It's not going to automatically
give you that raise.
But I hope I've demonstrated
that mindfulness
can in fact help
make us a little less
stressed, a little healthier,
more focused, maybe even
kinder and compassionate,
maybe even a bit more socially
responsible.
And since I started writing this
book, it's just gotten going.
We're still early days, but
the momentum is extraordinary.
"60 Minutes," Anderson Cooper
just did a big segment on.
And it appeared on the
cover of "Time" magazine.
Other tech companies,
like Intel and Adobe,
are adopting this
at breakneck speed.
And when I hear the good
work you're all doing here
and the tips that everyone
just naturally knows,
I really believe that
mindfulness and meditation
are on the verge of, in
a very good way, changing
the way we work.
Thank you all very much.
I'm happy to take any
questions if there are any.
Yeah, please, do you want
to get the mic first?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
It was great.
I'm just wondering, since
we're a technology company,
whether you think
that mindfulness
and some sort of,
like, inner serenity
is compatible with where
technology is going.
Because it looks like the
trend is developing technology
to grab more and more
of our attention.
So I was wondering if you
think it's totally compatible
or if there's a way to
actually build technology
for people to also
be able to detach.
DAVID GELLES: The
answer is both.
It's an incredible
tension right now.
And I think it's
one of the ironies
that Silicon Valley
is really the heart
of this mindfulness movement
in the United States.
I mean, there are
more tech companies
than in any other sector
that are adopting this.
So on the one hand,
yeah, having that screen
and that instant
impulse, I'm not always
mindful when I'm looking at
my iPhone and I-- or Android--
and I look at my Android
far too many times a day.
So on the one hand, it's
absolutely distracting us.
On the other hand,
there are apps
that are actually helping
us be much more mindful.
Headspace, I think, is
a company that Google's
worked with, founded by a
Brit named Andy Puddicombe.
It's fantastic,
and it actually is
kind of subverting technology
and using it to give us
cues and techniques
and tools and exercises
to become more mindful.
Another thing that's
happened is they are just
starting to develop these
neurofeedback devices, where
you can actually look at
how your brain waves are
performing.
And I did this.
When I had my head rigged
up to that EEG machine,
I was actually watching
my brain waves.
And when I meditated,
I could actually
see certain parts of
the electro activity
in my brain become more subdued.
And it was then that
I was being mindful.
And so there are, perhaps,
technologies on the horizon
that are going to actually
help us train our attention.
On balance, though, I
got to give it to you.
I mean, technology is
distracting us more and more,
which I would argue is why
it's more important than ever
that we find these moments,
that we find ways to be mindful
amidst all the technology.
Yeah, any other questions?
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
about kind of uptake or buy
in from people based on age.
So we had-- I joined
from LinkedIn,
and we had Fred Kofman,
who's the coach of our--
Jeff Weiner and also
Sheryl Sandberg.
So I don't know if
you know Fred Kofman.
He's pretty Buddhist, I think.
But he went in front
of a mass audience
of thousands of employees.
And we found that a lot
of the younger employees,
it may not sink in as much.
And also a lot of the examples
that you gave people, people
were, say, older, middle
aged or however you
want to definite it.
So I was wondering if
you've looked at that.
DAVID GELLES: I haven't, but I
think my initial impression is
that it's pretty
inter-generational.
And I think it largely depends
on the corporate culture.
And it's something I
didn't mention in the talk,
but there's no one
way to do this.
I mean, Google has
SIYLI, and it's
got the Search Inside Yourself
leadership Institute, which
is trying to offer the Search
Inside Yourself curriculum
to other companies.
And they're doing
some very good work,
but I think they're are also
finding that what works here
isn't going to necessarily
work at every company.
That's because this is
very sensitive material.
And so what I just demonstrated,
there's a whole range of ways
that this is showing up.
And I think in a company
like General Mills,
for example, where
the average employee
age is a bit older, they really
went in through the leadership
angle.
They said, this is
going to help you,
and these are
techniques and tools
that are going up help you
excel in a management role.
At a company like Medium,
Evan Williams' new company,
it's really for these
young engineers,
an amazing group of very
young, talented guys
is San Francisco-- guys
and girls, excuse me.
They are really using it to
be more focused and on the job
and more productive.
Because that's a
fast-moving startup up.
I didn't mention them, but they
have an amazing mindfulness
curriculum, working
with actually the son
of Jon Kabat-Zinn, who comes
in twice a week now, to Medium.
So I'm going to try
to resist being ageist
and be optimistic that it's
really accessible to people
on all ends of the spectrum.
Another question?
Yeah, Sam, is it?
AUDIENCE: Sam.
DAVID GELLES: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I, like quite a
lot of people here,
do commute quite long distances.
And whilst I'm committed to
trying to introduce moments
to pause whilst at work, do you
have any top tips for people
who want to make the
most of that, what
can be at times
quite stressful time,
and transform it into one that
can be a bit more mentally
nourishing?
DAVID GELLES:
Absolutely, I also try
to be mindful on the subway
of New York City, which
at rush hour, going through
Times Square where "The New
York Times" is located is
about all but impossible.
And so the one that
I've been working on
is actually mindful walking,
and not just focusing
on the subtle
sensations of my body,
but actually just being
more spatially aware.
And in a very
crowded environment,
I find that if I'm much
more attuned to my own body
and its relation to
other people around me,
I have less time to
just be caught up
and be anxious and
be kind of frustrated
with someone next to me and
someone pushing against me.
But I actually then
move a bit more
deliberately through
those crowds.
And so it seems ironic to
try to be actually more
aware of perhaps the last
place you'd like to be,
a crowded subway, but actually
bringing my attention to it
rather than just
trying to resist
it is actually
counter intuitively
the thing that I
find helps most.
So I don't know.
Give it a shot.
If it doesn't work,
try Headspace, an app.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAVID GELLES: Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: It kind of links
to the previous question,
actually, but a lot of the
examples in that were kind of I
guess people reaching
a stage in life,
having a catastrophic event
or a bit of an epiphany
or a life-changing moment
and kind of finding something
within themselves and having
that sort of realization.
With that in mind,
and sort of that
being an obvious way in which
lots of people come to this--
you can kind of
understand why-- how
do you best share this
with people who are maybe
slightly more on the
skeptic sort of scale?
DAVID GELLES: It's
a great question,
and I wish I had the
most easy answer.
But I guess I'd say,
even if we don't
have a life-changing,
catastrophic event,
we're all stressed.
And I think that's
why Jon Kabat-Zinn has
been so successful with
mindfulness-based stress
reduction-- tens of thousands of
people he's trained personally.
And if you just go in
through that door-- like,
are you stressed?
Yes, we're all stressed.
Would you like to be just
a little bit less stressed?
Yeah, OK.
And so even though we might
not have a catastrophe,
I think we're all suffering
in these little ways that
really do add up.
So I don't feel like that's
entirely satisfactory answer
myself, but I think
it's where we're at.
And a lot of people
do respond to even
those small, small changes.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: I just
have a quick one.
Thanks for the talk.
So we shared a lot of tips
for informal practice.
I was wondering what is
your formal practice?
DAVID GELLES: My formal
practice over the last 10 months
has been disrupted by a little
girl who's now 10 months old,
which is amazing.
And, really, she's my
greatest teacher now.
How many people in
the room are parents?
As you know, these little people
demand your entire presence
all the time.
They will not let you slip.
And I catch myself
when it's 5:00 AM.
She's up.
She wants to party, and I'm
still fast asleep in my head.
And it's so easy just
to glance at my iPhone.
And so it's just every time
I find myself doing that,
it's this queue to put
it down and actually just
be present, be
attentive with her.
So all of which is to
say, my formal practice,
until 10 months ago,
involved usually
in the morning--
that's when I sit best.
At the end of the day,
I find I'm so wound up
and I've got so many
things in my head
it's a little bit harder.
So for me, it tends
to be in the morning,
and I would sit anywhere
from 5 to 15 minutes,
during the weekday, to 50
minutes on the weekends.
Now, I'd say I get to
do that kind of formal
sitting practice less regularly,
a few times throughout the week
maybe.
But then I also have a group
of friends and professionals--
bankers, TV producers,
executives in New York City.
We meet a couple times
a month in the evening,
and we'll sit together
and have a discussion
about how things are going.
And then I also go
to evening workshops
at local meditation
centers in New York.
And I do feel like that's
less formal practice than I
might like.
But having had a roughly
formal practice for 15 years,
it's given me kind of
some momentum where
those little moments
throughout the day
are able to help maintain
some measure of equanimity.
Would I like to have
kind of my daily hour
where no one bothered me?
Absolutely, but as a mergers
and acquisitions reporter
with a 10-month-old,
not always so easy.
And that's true for everyone
in this room, I'm sure.
We all have very busy schedules,
so finding those little moments
throughout the day, throughout
the week, are crucial.
But they're possible.
Any other questions?
OK, oh, yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: The cover
is yellow there.
You changed it to blue.
Is there any reason for that?
DAVID GELLES: My publisher
changed it to blue.
So yellow is the US edition.
Blue is international.
AUDIENCE: Do you know why?
DAVID GELLES: I don't.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVID GELLES: Yeah, the
mysteries of the universe.
Thank you all so much.